mein name ist gerd in hagues arbeiter
und mann die tat
leopard 2 4 der kampf vor solchen bundes
verrät und wird die tonnen kampfgewicht
wir haben eine kanone darauf mit 120 mm
ebenso maschinengewehre und werden in
vielen verschiedenen bereichen
eingesetzt wird ein kampf was die körper
von agenturen ein feld immer mehr
wir sehen vier personen am anfang zu
haben habe ich einen fahrer einen laut
schätzungen richtete
unser grundsatz verständigt was wir
kommen will dafür ihren überlegen weil
guten morgen der grand prix stattfindet
und wieder die dame neben unserem beruf
näher bringen den körper mit diakon weil
man es einfach nie im leben meine sogar
ein schock
sofern für die damen informieren diese
ganze miterleben und für sich